[Music]
we got some fresh fish fellas welcome to
my jail
son you're in here cuz they say you got
to pay I'm in here to make sure you do
congratulations Adams you are a father
nobody told you you're going to spend
the rest of your life in here you ain't
never going to see
that
truth is I never thought about being a
father he's a little Mama's Boy you know
you don't have to be like him right I
just want to be there for my
[Music]
kid if Freedom's a state of mind I guess
my dream should be
enough just think about how much better
your kid's going to be without you
around
bco when you going to BR
up I ain't content with
dreaming humans are the greatest
weakness in any security
system prisons aren't inescapable they
just meant to feel that
way the street ad crime TR Mya my mind
need your help I know the game bro 23
when SLE even theind man see you think
reading's going to save your ass no I do
not sir I'm Str G have at it I'm so
close to not only freedom but also to
being a real
father I would like to help you I know
that more than anything in the
[Music]
world
think
think you can only protect yourself by
your choices oh my go plan I got to make
it back to
[Music]
the